[Music]
dennis joins us in wichita dennis
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you appreciate it how can we help
today
i have a uh well actually my daughter
has a situation she's uh 17 years old
um her mom got her a checking account
when she was 16 and she's been working
and putting money away
and being very responsible
well a couple days ago she got a message
on instagram from somebody she did not
know
uh
saying that they enjoyed some of her
pictures and they wanted to use her
pictures and they would pay her for it
well what they ended up doing was they
sent her a check via email
said okay
for three thousand dollars we're going
to pay you for
the pictures
you keep 500 and send us back that money
when you deposit the 2500
through zelly
so she did that i know
uh
i would have saw it instantly but i told
her but
things happened well anyway she didn't
think anything of it she went ahead and
as soon as she was the account said that
that money was there she sent it through
zelly to this individual
and then they tried it again
for another 2500
and then my ex-wife got a uh
email or i'm sorry a text message saying
that the account was overdrawn and
there's suspicious activity on it
and so they went in they filed a police
report with their local police they sent
it over to their the bank's asset
protection so my question is basically
this
um they're saying that they got the
second one stopped but the first one she
may be on the hook for three thousand
dollars
which i i mean i kind of agree with but
i kind of don't agree because i thought
there should be some better protection
on uh a checking account for a minor and
that's what it was
so what kind of
what did we do my my thought was just
let them sue her for the money get in
front of this way she gets in front of a
judge they can you know at least talk to
a impartial person the judge and say hey
this was scammed we shouldn't be owed
this they didn't do anything to protect
this this account from fraudulent
activities and project checks because
it's definitely fraudulent
yeah so we're just kind of what do we do
how honest can i be with you
perfectly go ahead all right um
i don't know what's uh state you're in
kansas there um every state's different
but if i'm a judge and you bring this to
me
i'm going to turn around and say where
were the parents of this minor
because they're ultimately in charge
when you open an account like that
and so yes a bank should have they're
going to open up an account for minors
there should be protections and all that
but
any to anything legally always rolls
downhill to the parent not always but
almost always rolls downhill to the
parents
or uphill to the parents
and so you can do that
i think this is an extraordinary
expensive
pull your hair out frustrating but
extraordinary
gift for your daughter if y'all frame
this right if you frame it as making
this the bank's fault then you're
teaching your daughter that if we make a
big mistake and we screw up even we
trying to do right we thought we'd get
then there's always somebody else to
blame if you teach your daughter um
man
we messed up you messed up big i'll
split this with you or you can work it
off in this way it's going to be very
expensive thing to learn
my promise is this never happens again
i just was dealing with somebody who's a
friend of mine who's got a college age
kids um was caught up in a sexting thing
in a very similar scam via instagram
and it was a mess caused a lot of
heartache and a lot of police reports
here's what i can promise you that will
never happen again
right and
i'm more interested in setting up a 17
year old with a 3 000 lesson usually
it's a car wreck or something like that
that you can learn a lesson like this
set it up a lesson like this and this
never happens again then i am about well
they should have had man i i personally
am not going to go down that road and if
i'm a judge i'm going to look at you dad
or look at your ex-wife and say where
were parents when this stuff was going
on
um that's my that's my take on it george
got thought yeah i just keep thinking
man this could be a
expensive road to go down just fighting
this thing in court when we get we even
know who this guy is and so as far as
recourse goes sure you can report it to
zell you can you know go after your bank
and say hey this was fraud this is
legitimate fraud but at the end of the
day there's a level of stupid tax here
where we have to go
okay red flag number four thousand if
they send me three thousand but i'm only
getting 500 this is a scam when they
overpay
and let me tell you uh i fell for this
john when i was younger i shipped a pair
of shoes on craigslist to nigeria
because he said it was first cousin and
i got a paypal email he paid extra for
the shipping and i thought wow this
guy's legit he really just wanted to
send this to his cousin it was a fake
email and it took a lot of sleuthing to
even figure out it was a fake email but
i should have checked my bank account
and said is this money actually there is
this actually in my paypal account and
so there's a lot of things we do as
teenagers and there's two people getting
scammed these days older folks and young
folks the people in the middle hopefully
know better but
especially young people they can be
susceptible because they're used to
venmo and zell this is in their world
but unless they're mailing me a check
and i go to the bank and cash that check
it's fraud i know i sound like a gong
george and hey dennis i appreciate your
vulnerability and i appreciate you
calling and asking i and i know things
are challenging because you're parenting
in two different households here this
young lady
if you were gonna hand a child a
smartphone
and you're gonna give them open access
to the internet to all social media and
let's let them go because they're just
kids
please do your due diligence and look at
what is happening to our young people
who are involved in this
just having free reign of the internet
free reign of these social media apps
free reign of
this is the best case scenario quite
honestly yeah that someone she got lost
she lost three thousand bucks and
learned a hard lesson
um the number of people over my years
working at colleges that were caught up
with pictures compromising pictures of
them that are out they could never get
back
um that people were taking their text
message i mean all kinds of stuff
parents
you have to be
in your kids business especially when
they're minors
well i don't want to be private they're
15 they're 17 they're 14 they're 13. get
in their business get in their business
we don't let them buy beer we don't let
them buy smokes we don't let them go to
war we don't let them buy guns because
we know that their brains aren't fully
formed yet we hand them the internet and
say make good choices right and there's
entire industries that are built on
on preying on these young folks parents
get involved have that conversation and
say here here's the ground rules also if
anyone asks you for money wants to give
you money this is a conversation that
goes straight to the parents and we talk
about it or be a luddite and just
don't give your kid access to the
internet
john no one's ever wanted to buy my
photos that i post on instagram
so
and i'm gonna be i'm a big deal john so
i don't know what what she got on here
no one's ever
i'm not gonna oh you know what someone
reached out and said they'd like to pay
for my pictures of my feet
that's what i thought i'm gonna hard
nope on that we're not gonna be friends
i hope that was rhetorical like you're
talking about someone else
no
dear lord
okay
and if they're reaching out to oh god
help us parents social get involved in
your kids lives
get involved in your kids lives you're
not being a helicopter parent you are
being wise
be a caring parent yeah well this is not
encroaching on their privacy this is
helping them avoid some huge mistakes a
three thousand dollars got two little
dogs do they have their own account uh
you know if they could open a bank
account john i would i would know about
an instagram account oh yeah one of
them's got one we don't post though come
on we're better than that we gave up on
it did you yeah like just it's just you
and me a couple of years ago are you
being honest you give up on it 100 you
can go check it i'm proud of you george
thank you i know it's hard social media
is hard enough on your own let alone
posting for an animal that can't post
for itself but some good lessons here
john social media i think this is one of
these things this generation has to
grapple with and go what's the healthy
way to use this yeah absolutely because
it's going to happen more and more
and more and more and more and more and
more yeah so parents need to have these
conversations set some ground rules set
some boundaries get so that we don't end
up in a situation like this yeah it's
sad i hate that for you brother i hate
that dennis i hate that i hate that i
hate that man hate this for your little
girl too i hope she gets the money back
somehow that'd be great but i've heard
with these zelle scams it can be really
difficult to get your money back
not a lot of recourse on this but she
gets it back call us up let us know
we'll cheer on with you man